say I hope you're wearing your green
everybody now most people are familiar
with the more common st. Patrick's dines
Day traditions like the parade
shepherd's pie the local news and foxy
boxing but there's more to the holiday
than just that I mean we're celebrating
st. Patrick it's like who was he what's
his story who is he I don't actually
know what he did I think that we should
have looked it up look this up luckily I
phone I shut up kiss me i'm iphone okay
uh what is the wireless that we're here
anyway Gandalf 69 in the password Frodo
69 I wish that wasn't okay hmm ireland
ireland ireland ireland ireland and not
getting i think my phones being weird
well i do know that in leprechaun one
the movie that the leprechauns weakness
was that he had to shine any shoe that
he came into contact with so the people
went around their house with their bag
and they got all the shoes from the
house and then they threw them at
leprechaun on the front lawn to slow
them down you know that makes sense
because now that you mention that i'm
remembering the story of st. Patrick and
I believe he had to drive all the rats
out of ireland's using a special flute
and what he probably did was he played a
song to make them throw their shoes in
the ocean then he was like go shine your
shoes you rats and then in leprechaun
too he rides around in a go-cart